[Music]
deja vu is usually a glitch in the
matrix
[Music]
it happens when they change something
[Music]
why use old code
to mirror something new
maybe this isn't the story you think it
is
[Music]
what happens when they change something
[Applause]
what's up squirrel
you sleep all right
no we got to get going seriously she
won't
stop kicking come on facebook
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
in a perfect world
none of this ever would have happened
androids were a part of our everyday
life
hot chocolate
and then one night
everything changed
we've gotta get to boston before i give
birth
it's the only safe place
how long would that take two weeks
you can find a safe way for us to go
i'll go
i'm fighting a war against an enemy that
literally never sleeps
killing machines they won't stop so
we're all dead
we gotta get through no man's land
without being noticed
no checkpoints
no humans
a lot of androids
would have to be quiet
silent
i'd have to be
an android rebellion leads to the
extinction of human life
i would kill for you i would die for you
that would be the same for our baby
my son i'm going to give you the only
thing that i have left
a chance
playback
this is the entertainment capital of the
world
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running
johnny you're gonna be working with the
number one choreographer in red shore
city yuck that is rubbish so bad wow
he's freaking me out
i don't
i'm really having second thoughts about
this
[Music]
i can't do this can i try this girl
you're terrific but can she act
take that you nasty alien monster
did i do good oh boy
you have no idea what you're getting
into
whatever podunk town they crawled out of
that's where they belong
we cannot let that bully steal our hopes
and dreams guts hey these are the things
you need now
good evening it is my pleasure to
present to you a brand new show
featuring the return of clay
[Music]
[Music]
the journey of a lifetime is about to
begin
[Music]
i don't suppose any of you can tap dance
huh
[Music]
hello peter do i know you we started
getting some visitors from every
universe this is all my fault
i promise i'll fix this
we're gonna get through this
we're gonna get to it together
december 17th
welcome to stoker the birthplace of
monster wrestling this is incredible but
for this once proud city to survive
a new champion must rise
steve wake up are you pretending to be
asleep right now
listen steve might not look like much
but there is a champion monster inside
of him did he eat one
thank you that felt great
maybe they're right winning's not really
my thing not yet we start training
tomorrow
6am
you're you're serious
let's start over what do you love to do
sleeping really sitting not helping oh
there's also dancing what
i don't like dancing that's so
[Music]
okay yes
i love this wrestling is 80
footwork
not bad for 22 tons
are you ready to save this city yeah
execute plan tango
holy guacamole and chips for lunch today
you want to kiss a very questionable
opponent and dancing it's a disgrace to
the sport for a total joke that's how i
felt my whole life but you believed in
me
okay enough with the sappy stuff ah it's
showtime we need to beat the biggest
hammer
the baddest
this is gonna be fun
[Music]
it is go bro
[ __ ] up put your game face on
and if you live let's get froyo
afterwards oh i love froze wait if i
live
i still can't believe it
you're gonna fall in love with a new
little person again
just breathe
i'm gonna count down from three
and on three
and two and one
three
[Music]
i can't lie to my family anymore
[Music]
the second you tell your wife that you
are dying
your opportunity to do this is gone
[Music]
you want to go say hi
[Music]
[Music]
so he has everything even the memories
you store deep in your subconscious
do this with us and let life go on for
your family a clean swab
what's going on
can't figure out what the right thing is
here
i thought i had more time i guess
you have an opportunity here i'm not
done i didn't say you're dying
i feel like i've fallen in love with it
for the first time again
you don't like this you think i like
this being told i'm not me because
you're not me
you are not
i love you cam antenna
[Music]
let's hop on one of those ships and sail
away
that sounds nice
you got company
why don't you think about where we would
go
far
far
away from here
come on
[Music]
i was just thinking about my mother
what was she like
beautiful
shattered
you are not here
you wish
this angel
finest girl west of the rockies i have
to meet her you are not home
what's your pleasure mister the truth is
i
i didn't come here for
that you have been broken your innocence
holding they're gonna marry me
take me away from here
[Music]
do not give way to such feelings as
these
they will ruin your happiness
[Music]
you can't choose enough you won't
[Music]
she just does not love you she is using
you you have no idea
who she is
you have to stop thinking that i'm gonna
be something that i'm not
that way is home
your choice
[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just iron that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestructible
great i'm the only one who didn't get
any superpower
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
which is which is crazy i didn't even
know that was a thing but it's like a
dog water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy canine here what is a k-9
invade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
it's expired sir oh come on man you know
how many times i've been in and out of
this gate with that excuse me what's the
odds on isis it's about the vehicle
shirt you want me to step out of here
he's with ranger battalion
ranger battalion
i've been busting my ass to get my mind
and my body back into a good place i
need to get back in the game sir you
want to get back in the game prove it
sergeant rodriguez was a legend family
funeral sunday outside of nogales they
won his dog at the funeral you do this
and you're back in the game
she won't work with anyone one minute
she's good the next minute she's sending
three guys to the er what's up dawg and
you're gonna go on a little road trip
easy we got so scared smell it out [ __ ]
what is your deal man maybe just take
crazy down one notch
[Music]
right no no no no
no you're just a demon you're just a
demon
whatever happened to you dogs you used
to be 11.
[Music]
you're so good how'd you make her get
out of your hand i just talked to her
see she's just a noodle she just needs
so good
[Music]
you don't do anything else psychotic on
this trip maybe we can have some fun is
that a deal
lulu is that you good girl you give hugs
now really lulu gets the best of you've
never had a lulu
no we don't we don't we don't exactly
hug
so you're telling me that nuke was just
as messed up as luanne had to work him
every day for six months when he stopped
struggling that's when i realized maybe
i could stop struggling too
it's okay it's just lightning right
look at that
she's never slept in a nice bed before
there ain't no shame in wanting a big
comfy mattress i was hoping you might
have a room for me and my little girl is
that a purple heart was she wounded um
yes she she was thank you for your
service
i've never seen this dog exhibit any
aggressive behavior before never she
loves people
[Music]
oh my god i can i can see
you're definitely not the girl i thought
i'd be in the tub with but
i'll take what i can get at this point i
guess
july 20th
1969.
[Music]
in school you were taught that apollo 11
lost contact with the world for two
minutes
[Music]
not true
they found something on that day
that they kept him for 50 years
and now
it's too late to stop
in breaking news the governor has just
ordered the mass evacuation of the
entire west coast
moving to higher ground it's the only
possible chance of surviving
stay away my brothers and sisters
stay
this planet
has suffered five
extinctions this
is going to be the sixth
oh he dead
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
[Music]
[Music]
it's been a year 16 months
you're a hard guy to get to really know
do you even want a family
i do want a family
[Music]
my name's perry i i work for grace
he wants you hit this address
i get that
[Music]
i know who you are i know your name of
course your reputation precedes you
work for me i'm done with that
you're going to be fun to have a route
440 grand in here
we're going to make this exchange or i'm
just going to take it
do have some balls
can i find out excuse me boys
do you guys mind moving out of the way
maybe somewhere over there
do you want to grab yours i'll grab mine
where are you driving off to in the
middle of a tuesday right
you know not much
[Music]
you got away
you know what this guy really knows how
to handle himself
so that makes things a little harder
[Applause]
oh my god
let me get you out of here okay i'm sure
you will you're here to take me thank
you
i went out of here too
can you run
can you run no but i'm gonna hop like
hell
[Music]
i'm gonna get away from all this
violence
starting
now yeah now's good
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a long way from home
[Music]
this is way tell me you're going to help
me get my sister back
i've seen the bodies
they're terrorists the killers ain't
that what you do
we need you
you reckon you can get us in there
easy
i'm gonna make this right
so i'm gonna go into that bunker
and we're gonna kill every last one of
those sons of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
oh what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
oh yes
it's one hell of a lovely skull good
work rhys you dumb son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
uh
what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] me
[Music]
this is it
moment of truth
remember might be easter success don't
screw up
come on
i can't watch
but i can't look away
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing
that ever happened to me
i can't believe we got to be seen with
that freak chicken here everybody laughs
at me dad what'd you expect he's mostly
chicken no he's mostly hair shaking
sounds like they're cheering for you
chicken hair chicken hair chicken
if i can bring back the hamster of
darkness everyone shall accept
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
follow me
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly trials
why can't it ever be two trials
captain
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh please
you couldn't have brought the extra
large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't fly you
can watch
i can't fly
[Music]
i will ask you simple questions you will
answer in short sentences only what you
believe to be absolute truth
absolute truth
i can do that
now
brief as you can
what is your name
stanton carlisle
are you a true medium yes i am
mr carla doctor how about that
please lie down
[Music]
can you read minds yes i can under the
right circumstances
keep your answers brief
what do i want to be found out same as
everybody else
are you in contact with the beyond
well we've had our share of snake
charmers in the past
we deal with them
it's time that you delivered
when does it end
i want to know
if you displease the right people the
world closes in on you very very fast
[Music]
uh
hear it not duncan void it's a now
that summons thee to heaven
or to hell
world is in shock as a group of
terrorists has taken control of large
areas of syria and iran
the world can be a cruel and dangerous
place
remember
even if you're afraid
be strong
your loving mother fatima
[Music]
did your mother ever tell you the story
of the lady of heaven
[Music]
she was very special
daughter to the prophet muhammad
my time is near
and after with my lovely fatima
you will face many trials
with my father no longer here to lead us
evil is with those who will extinguish
the light of truth
god will judge all of you
lady fatima's goodness
inspired people to stand up
no matter what the cost
her legacy lives on
do you know anything about wine a little
you're a lightsaber i'm chris
skye
two sudden adventures it's a sudden
adventure
[Music]
hey get away from my car man we don't
want any problems
ladies you're two weeks behind on the
rent again you're not gonna say anything
explain where you were all night
i saw something on the news lisa it's
your roommate
scott i should probably contact the
police that would be stupid of me why
expecting a package
how's the knee dude i do good work don't
i
everything goes loverboy
stripping down to the studs
oh this was set up now you're catching
on
you are a very naughty girl
that's scary right i need all your
passwords and security codes
are you going to get chris so you want
me to call the police he's right here
daddy what
my name is christopher decker there's a
woman in my house she's imprisoning me
against my will she's trying to steal my
identity she wants to kill me
thank god you came back chris thought i
might lose you forever i'm better now
you should have seen a look on your face
[Music]
[Music]
stay back
afraid of the dark
i love the dark
[Music]
ah
[Music]